et c'est vrai que la semaine dernière en
parlant de cette affaire qui m'a
énormément touché qui a tous touché
c'est vrai que moi j'ai une petite fille
de 11 ans et j'ai pas pu m'empêcher de
me mettre à la place des parents bien
entendu et la semaine dernière
on était avec Georges Fennec ancien
magistrat et
j'ai dit j'ai dit que pour
la présumer coupable présumer innocente
présumé coupable on va dire
pour moi je n'aurais fait un procès très
très rapide et j'aurais déclaré
perpétuité tout de suite et ce qui est
fou c'est que tout le monde enfin
beaucoup les bien-pensants les
toute la population le plus grand nombre
de personnes étaient d'accord avec moi
et
il est toujours les donneurs de leçons
les bien-pensants sont servis de ça pour
détourner l'affaire alors que l'affaire
aujourd'hui c'est que Lola n'est plus là
et ils ont détourné l'affaire pour dire
que c'était une admissible de dire ça
aujourd'hui et ben écoutez moi je le
redis je le redis surtout quand je vois
ces images pour moi c'est procès très
rapide et perpétuité pour la personne
qui a fait ça je suis désolé
Eric Dupond-Moretti a dit que retourner
au Moyen-Âge pour moi c'est leur méthode
qui sont celles du moyen-âge et quand on
voit aujourd'hui ce qui se passe en
France quand on voit aujourd'hui
le drame
et moi et tous ceux qui nous regardent
ce soir sont obligés de se mettre à la
place de des parents de la famille de
Lola
quand un ministre de la Justice
quand les éditorialistes
au lieu de parler tu drame
parle
de ma sortie et disent on est au
Moyen-âge et quand Eric Dupond m'aurait
dit pour Moretti prononce 4 fois mon nom
dans C'est à vous dans une mission pour
dire que c'est inadmissible ce qui est
inadmissible monsieur Dupont-Moretti
ce qui est inadmissible c'est que cette
personne est fait ça c'est pas ce que
j'ai dit qui est inadmissible et je
pense que tous les Français qui ont
suivi l'histoire et tous les Français
qui nous regardent parce que le plus
inadmissible dans l'histoire
c'est ce qui s'est passé c'est pas mes
propos et je le redis monsieur
Dupont-Moretti je le redis à tous les
donneurs de leçon je le redis à tous
ceux qui font des éditos et qui font des
postes sur les réseaux sociaux à tous
les biens pensants qui sont pour moi les
mal pensant
qui sont aujourd'hui responsables de la
société dans laquelle nous sommes
qui sont pour moi ceux qui sont
responsables de tous les drames qu'on
vit
parce que moi je ne veux plus qui aide à
faire Lola
je ne veux plus qui aide à faire Lola et
je veux
non moi je ne suis personne je ne suis
pas représentant du gouvernement je sais
pas représentant de la justice mais en
tant que citoyen français je pense que
tous les citoyens pensent la même chose
on veut que ça ne se reproduise plus et
on veut qu'il y ait une peine exemplaire
aujourd'hui pourquoi j'avais dit que je
voulais et que je souhaitais et que la
français souhaitait cette affaire soit
vite réglée on m'a dit à l'enquête bien
sûr qu'il y a l'enquête aujourd'hui les
éléments de l'enquête on en aura bien
sûr petit à petit mais aujourd'hui la
présumée coupable il y a
très peu de chou on sait que on sait que
c'est une présumée coupable on dit on
utilise le mot présumé
et pour tout le monde
c'est la coupable
elle a fait des aveux en plus
aujourd'hui pourquoi attendre des
semaines des mois des années pour que ce
procès est Dieu pourquoi on doit
attendre pourquoi les parents de Lola
vont devoir attendre des semaines et des
mois avant d'avoir le jugement ça veut
dire qu'ils vont y penser ils vont venir
ils vont peut-être dans un an dans un an
et demi ils vont devoir aller au procès
vous rendez compte en décompte
le drame pour eux
et aujourd'hui il y a des éditorialistes
il y a des je vous dis des personnes qui
disent et qui ne parlent même plus
du meurtre atroce de Lola mais qui parle
juste et qui font juste des postes
sur le fait que j'ai dit que cette
personne
qui a commis un acte inadmissible abject
ne doit avoir et doit avoir un procès
très rapidement et avoir la perpétuité
et là tout le monde dit c'est
inadmissible ce qui a dit Cyril Hanouna
écoutez-moi bien vous êtes dit vous
dites peut-être que c'est inadmissible
enfin pour moi ce qui est inadmissible
c'est de faire des tweets et de faire
des édito là dessus pour moi
ça c'est la vie de la société
je vous le dis
et c'est très grave d'avoir fait des
tweets là-dessus de faire des édits
là-dessus que le ministre de la Justice
au lieu de parler et de dire ce qui va
se passer ensuite pour Lola et de dire
ou ce qui va se passer et si le procès
va être vite fait ce que les réponses
des Français la seule chose qui a trouvé
à dire Eric Dupond-Moretti ministre de
la Justice garde des sceaux
on a l'extrait c'est parler de moi
donc il fasse son travail et qui retonne
des comptes et qui rendent des comptes
aux Français au plus vite sur cette
affaire au lieu de parler de moi merci
2 millions de téléspectateurs je
m'imagine à mieux faire connaître la
justice à montrer combien la justice
c'est difficile de la rendre et on
balaye ça d'un revers de manche
il dit Monsieur Hanouna ça c'est
l'époque dans laquelle nous vivons il
faut s'adapter à l'époque mais si c'est
ça l'époque dans laquelle on vit on est
tombé franchement bien bas c'est la
négation de l'État de droit l'État de
droit il nous protège
il vous protège il me protège il nous
protège tous
il protège monsieur Hanouna aussi et le
balayer comme ça pour au fond flatter
les bases instincts faire de le dire de
l'audimat moi c'est quelque chose qu'à
titre personnel je ne peux pas accepter
monsieur le ministre déjà apparemment
vous ne connaissez pas la télé on fait
pas de l'audience c'est pas de
l'audiment là-dessus c'est que
l'émission elle marche tous les jours on
n'a pas besoin de ça je vous le dis nous
on parle des sujets qui touchent les
Français on essaie de faire avancer des
choses comme il y a un instant Mathilda
qui attendait que les les autorités
fassent quelque chose pour elle depuis
des semaines et des mois comme pour de
nombreuses personnes qui viennent ici et
qui disent que la France nous tourne pas
rond et qui disent que la justice ne
tourne pas
y a-t-il un problème avec la justice en
France
monsieur Dupont-Moretti si vous me
regardez ce soir je vous invite à venir
à être invité puisque vous allez souvent
sur des plateaux je vous vois faire le
tour des plateaux télé venez ici vous
allez avoir vous allez voir des Français
parce qu'apparemment vous les voyez pas
ou les entendez pas
vous n'avez pas vu de français si vous
allez voir des Français qui vont vous
parler et qui vont vous dire ce qui
ressentent parce qu'aujourd'hui monsieur
Dupont-Moretti j'ai l'impression que
vous êtes déconnecté vous êtes un très
grand avocat c'est certainement un très
bon un très bon ministre du la justice
mais aujourd'hui les questions que se
posent les Français surtout les réponses
vous ne leur donnez pas
et la faire Lola on attend d'un ministre
de la Justice on attend pas ça d'un
ministre de la Justice on n'attend pas
qu'il vienne parler d'un animateur
pendant deux heures
moi je donnais mon opinion mon opinion
de père de famille et j'ai donné mon
opinion de citoyens vous vous êtes un
responsable politique donc vous n'avez
pas donné votre opinion sur moi vous
êtes là pour donner des réponses aux
Français pour donner des échéances que
va-t-il se passer sur cette affaire ça
vous a pas entendu là dessus donc noyez
le poisson et parlez de moi
pour ne pas répondre aux questions et
aux vraies questions
je pense que c'est pas la bonne solution
de les éditorialistes
qui ont fait ça et qui ont essayé de
faire de l'humour sur cette affaire de
l'humour sur l'affaire Lola Sofia France
Inter service public
ce matin Sophia Aram nous reproche aussi
d'avoir dit que j'ai dit cette phrase
que j'ai dit cette pour cette dame
c'était
pour moi c'est un monstre excusez-moi ce
qu'elle a fait c'est monstrueux ce
monstre j'ai dit c'est procès direct et
perpétuité
on m'a reproché on m'a dit que j'étais
je pensais comme l'extrême droite moi je
comme on m'a dit non il pense comme
l'extrême gauche prénom Mady pense au
milieu je veux dire aujourd'hui moi je
fais pas de politique j'ai juste un père
de famille et un citoyen qui voit qu'en
France tous les jours en faisant une
émission de société en faisant une
émission en direct tous les jours
il y a des drames tous les jours
et qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on va
pleurer
on est tous triste et on va voir quoi
des images comme ça dans une semaine
dans deux semaines d'un autre drame et
on va dire ah oui il faut attendre on va
attendre l'enquête on va attendre le
procès 18 mois un an on saura même 20 24
mois on sera même pas ce qui ce qui
s'est passé
et on va tous oublier mais il faut pas
qu'il faut pas qu'on oublie parce que si
c'est passé pour Lola faut pas qu'on
l'oublie
et avec des discours comme celui d'Éric
Dupont-Moretti
je vous le dis
c'est sans cesse à recommencement parce
qu'il va faire quoi il va revenir sur un
plateau quand il y aura un autre drame
puis il va dire on attend on attend que
la justice fasse son travail
on a plus envie d'attendre que la
justice fasse son travail il faut
qu'elle le fasse il faut qu'elle le
fasse au plus vite et il faut je pense
je vais en parler avec des spécialistes
qui est une justice au cas par cas pour
un cas comme celui-ci il faut accélérer
les choses je dis pas qu'il faut j'ai
pas dit qu'il fallait pas de procès
parce qu'il y en a beaucoup qui ont mal
compris ou qui regardent pas l'émission
ou qui ont vu des choses traîner ici ou
là il faut bien sûr un procès mais il
faut approcher rapide il faut une
perpétuité rapide je ne vois pas
pourquoi on se pose la question dans un
cas comme celui-là je suis désolé
excusez-moi de dire ça pourquoi on se
pose la question alors bien sûr qu'il y
aura un procès mais il faut que le
procès soit rapide et que cette personne
soit vite jugée pour que la famille Lola
pour que la France entière se dise au
moins ça a été vite au moins il y a une
justice exemplaire
là qu'est-ce qu'on va se dire on va
oublier et ça c'est inadmissible